rendre justice aux femmes victimes de la
révolution mais aussi actrice sur le
terrain politique par la violence
parfois théroigne de méricourt a pris
les armes olympe de gouges rédige une
déclaration des droits de la femme et de
la citoyenne
elles sont également
dans un moment où la violence qu'elle
revendique va permettre précisément de
les évacuer assez rapidement de la
sphère politique au motif de leur
dangerosité supposée au motif de leur
caractère passionné qui est rendu
responsable d'un certain nombre d'excès
de la révolution française ce qui est
d'autant plus paradoxale qu'elles en
sont en fait les victimes privilégiées
en mars 1789 les femmes marchent sur
versailles à travers des peintures
l'exposition retrace leur histoire
jusqu'au début du 21e siècle
trois salles sont consacrées à charlotte
corday le musée possédant la plus grande
collection mondiale d'oeuvre à son
propos elle est intéressante puisqu'elle
a une double mémoire c'est d'abord pour
certains l'héroïne qui a sauvé le peuple
de mara le sanguinaire donc ça c'est
plutôt l'historiographie d'une tradition
réactionnaire qui est sa et d'insister
sur les méfaits de la révolution et puis
elle est également pour un autre courant
plutôt républicain l'ennemi public celle
qui a attenté au jour de l'ami du peuple
celle qui a donc voulu combattre le
processus révolutionnaire issues de
collections privées et local les oeuvres
exposées sont pour la plupart inédites
pour se plonger dans deux siècles et
2000 d'imaginaire de la violence et des
femmes sous la révolution